was that a go hi I'm Christy Kumari the
executive director for the Center for
social innovation here at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
all of you who are joining us on YouTube
for a guest presentation in our new csr
course here at the GSB this new course
social innovation through corporate
social responsibility is taught by
Professor Dave Brady and me we are
honored and thrilled to have Deborah
Dunn as our guest tonight talking about
stakeholder theory Deborah is a member
of the faculty at the has ou plasma
Institute of design here at Stanford
also known as the D school Deborah is
spearheading new efforts on coursework
as well as projects on new issues around
sustainable abundance she is an advisor
to startups and social ventures all over
the globe she sits on the board of the
Skoll foundation B lab and global giving
in addition to all those leadership
activities Deborah is here tonight to
talk to us based on her career as an
executive with hewlett-packard for 22
years
Deborah's most recent position was as a
senior VP of corporate affairs and
global citizenship prior to that she was
VP of strategy and corporate operations
Deborah has worked at HP and the
manufacturing division led teams in
human resource marketing and it's that
diverse skillset across corporate
division that gives her a unique
perspective as we talked tonight about
stakeholder theory and corporate social
responsibility Deborah got her BA at
Brown she got her MBA at that other
school on the East Coast that Stanford
doesn't like to talk about yeah Harvard
I've been fortunate to know Deborah
personally and professionally for the
past few years and I find whenever I'm
at one of those strategic crossroads
I called Deborah she is at the top of my
list of people whose advice I seek out
and what I find with Deborah is she has
an uncanny and gifted ability to take
global changes emerging trends political
forces synthesize synthesize that
material and make it relevant to the
choices you're making for your organ
zatia and I find whenever I leave with
Deborah I have one of those aha moments
I feel I'm on a better strategic path
and in some 1/2 hour with Deborah is
much more valuable than many hours with
a multitude of executives that I've
spoken with and so with that welcome
Deborah done and we're getting shut up
now well Chris thank you for that very
generous introduction it will be hard to
live up to the expectations you set but
I'll give it my best so first I just
wanted to anchor my comments in a little
bit of context about my background and
experience and how I've come to my point
of view so I think significantly I grew
up in a blue-collar family I was the
first in my immediate family to go to
college I went to brown at Brown I
studied comparative economics I was
really interested in trying to find an
Economic Forum that allowed for more
democratic participation and I actually
ended up writing a thesis on consumer
coops and working in the coop space when
I left Brown in a nonprofit organization
that did consulting and training with
food and housing co-ops all over the US
and Canada after spending a little bit
of time in the nonprofit space I got a
little frustrated with the pace the lack
of the kind of progress that I was
looking for so I moved back to Boston
I'd spent a little time in Michigan
working in on profit world moved back to
Boston worked for the Massachusetts
government for a year actually running
an energy conservation program which I
now find kind of amusing given the way
we've gone full circle on that topic in
the low-income community doing basically
housing upgrades low-cost housing
upgrades to reduce energy consumption
low-income community if I had been
frustrated by the pace of progress in
the nonprofit world I was incredibly
government I was actually working for a
former brown professor who had gone to
work for the government really excited
about having a mandate to drive change
and I encountered lots of people in the
organization who'd been there a long
time
we're quite clear that they would be
there long after he left and that he was
not going to have a lot of impact on the
way they lived their lives on a day to
day basis so really eye-opening
experience but it led me to decide
business had all the money business had
all the power if you really want to have
an impact you had to go into business so
I got into Harvard got my MBA and when I
graduated I first of all wanted a
legitimizing credential I'd had this
sort of weird broad range of experience
and I also wanted to work for an own
company that I felt I could really
resonate with from a values perspective
youlet Packard was a company that at
that time was getting lots of visibility
lots of notoriety for the HP way and for
the values of Hewlett and Packard and
that all resonated with me I interviewed
there I got a job expecting to be there
for about two years and I left in 2005
22 years later having enjoyed an
incredibly broad and diverse career
primarily in line management so at the
division level I managed most functions
marketing manufacturing Human Resources
I ran a division I was Lou Platts chief
of staff I had a bunch of corporate
functions after Carly came in including
strategy and communication as Chris
mentioned and then my very last job was
as an officer of the company and a
member of the Executive Council running
everything related to global citizenship
and that was a very interesting and
exciting opportunity at an exciting time
to have that kind of visibility in the
the mainstream corporate world so on
this whole topic of stakeholder theory
before I get into the details of HP to
me there are a couple really simple
questions that are a part of all this
the first and most obvious is whose
interests should a company serve should
it be the global community should it be
the local community where
company actually has physical operations
should it be partners of the company
supply chain partners other partners
should it be employees should it be
customers should it be investors should
be all of these should they have the
same weight should shareholder primacy
actually be the mode that's sort of the
current thinking in many business
circles that the shareholder is number
one by a long shot and others get
factored in as it helps fuel profit at
the end of the day this really is the
question and I think in pursuing a
career in business it's important to
understand how you answer that question
and why the other big question is over
what time frame should you be thinking
about the interests of all of these
various stakeholders or players should
you be focused on the next quarter the
next fiscal year your option vesting
period should you be focused on the
lifetime of your grandchildren I mean
this makes a huge difference in
determining how you would make any given
decision because it is often the case
that if you take a longer timeframe you
would almost automatically consider a
much wider set of players in considering
how you make a particular decision so I
want to go back in time a little bit
when I start talking about HP and I want
to talk about the so called DNA for
corporate social responsibility at HP it
was the common wisdom and the common
talk when I was coming up in my
corporate career that if you just built
a sense of corporate social
responsibility into the DNA of a company
that was all that was needed the right
decisions would be made the right
stakeholders would be considered and so
there are three dimensions of that but I
want to talk about in terms of HP's
background one is the original thinking
about HP's reason for being and the
is often quoted in many of you have
perhaps seen it in 1940 Dave Packard was
speaking to a group of CEOs when he said
many assumed wrongly
the company exists simply to make money
the real reason HP exists is to make a
contribution to improve the welfare of
humanity to advance the frontiers of
science profit is not the proper end aim
of management is what makes all the
proper ends and aims possible and
through I would say the majority of my
career at HP that was largely the sense
now that also got manifested through the
company's corporate objectives and I
want to highlight a couple specifically
because while the list is not
necessarily novel there are many
companies that might have similar items
on their list of corporate objectives I
think the framing of some of the
objectives is somewhat novel especially
in today's world and also is very
related to this concept of who are the
rightful stakeholders of the company so
these objectives were first documented
in 1958 and I'm not going to highlight
them all I'm just gonna highlight a few
that I think are particularly
significant first profit the specific
wording was to achieve sufficient profit
not to maximize profit to achieve
sufficient profit to finance our company
growth and provide the resources we need
to achieve other corporate objectives I
think that thinking about profit was
very significant and very informative in
terms of the way people made decisions
fields of interest to participate in
those fields of interest that offer
opportunities for continuing growth and
that enable us to make a needed and
profitable contribution so in deciding
what businesses do we go in how do we
expand
those were the kinds of decisions that
were made our people to help HP people
share in the company's success which
they make possible and to help them gain
a sense of satisfaction and
accomplishment from their work and
finally citizenship to honor our
obligations to society by being an
economic intellectual and social asset
to each nation and each community in
which we operate and I think that view
that it was the role of a leadership
team at HP to ensure that the company
really was an asset that people embraced
HP as a company coming to their
community or their country because of
the many things that H we would bring
not just in terms of paying taxes and
offering jobs but in terms of actively
contributing to the welfare of the
community so I would say that in terms
of stakeholders and I'm going to get
into this in more detail but during the
bill and Dave error era if you ask
someone who are the stakeholders they
would mention four groups and I've used
different types eyes to indicate who
really got the most significant weight
during different periods of the
company's history in the early days
employees and customers followed by
communities and investors were clearly
viewed as as stakeholders Wall Street
was not so powerful quarterly earnings
calls were not happening when this
company was founded hewlett-packard
always owned a big piece and even when
in theory they needed to be paying more
attention to their investors it just
wasn't their way of being in the world
employees were always huge because there
was a real view of partnership in
building the success of the company
and I think all of the the reward
strategies the benefit programs and
approaches as well as we can were
managed reflected that the kind of
leeway people had to make a difference
you see some of that now reflected in
some new companies like Google things
like giving people a lot of
discretionary time to go off and pursue
ideas that they find interesting that
are not dictated top-down those kinds of
things were pioneered very very early on
at HP during the transition period and
I'm referring to the transition period
as the time between Hewlett and Packard
being actively involved in any way and
even the time that they were beginning
to fail even if they weren't completely
gone to the recent period so the post
Carly era there was still family members
on the board there still was a lot of
legacy of HP during those interim years
and that really is was the end of my
involvement at HP investors definitely
started to be the number one focus a
priority employees were losing a little
ground I would say it was investors
followed by customers employees and
community were still up there and then
under the Mark Hurd era there was
another very significant shift with
employees being almost treated as a
necessary evil
obviously HP is a big company it's very
decentralized so you can find exceptions
to this in particular organizations
within the company but if you look at
what happened to employee benefit
programs and what happened to the
overarching corporate level approaches
to employees very significant change in
that era investors became even more of
the principal focus customers of course
are a focused because there is a view
that you can't succeed if you don't pay
some attention to customers and
communities lost a lot of ground
so I want to dive a little bit into that
middle era in terms of okay we cared
about these stakeholders what did that
mean in terms of programs and policies
and what we actually did so I'm going to
use this chart this chart is the global
citizenship framework that we use to
talk about what does it mean for HP to
be a global citizen the way we
articulated our field of play if you
will in terms of global citizenship and
I think very significantly in the center
of this chart is ethics and governance
and you may recall that during this
period we had just undergone Enron we
were watching some huge ethical breaches
in major companies that were causing
significant pain to employees
communities investors that was very much
on the tongues of people ethics had
always been a big focus for youlet and
Packard many would say it was too hard
to get fired at HP however everyone knew
that if you committed ethical misconduct
you would get fired it was just in
grained into the company big focus on
governance sarbanes-oxley passed lots of
effort into providing more transparency
around all of our governance processes
community engagement was also a big
focus and to us community engagement
historically and during this period was
largely about unleashing employees to
work in communities that were co-located
with HP facilities and so that those
activities ranged from things like
individual businesses adopting
organizations in their community and
donating equipment and donating time and
doing volunteer activities
we did a lot of that particularly in
schools throughout the US and more
broadly it also involved more radical
activities like some of the inclusion
stuff that I will talk about but
explicit volunteer policies giving
people time pay time off to go and do
volunteer work on behalf of the company
and really encouraging that was part of
the community engagement philosophy and
I think there was a strong view that and
a lot of feedback from employees that
they really valued the company because
they felt like the company supported
them in doing things that they really
cared about in their community and in
helping make their community a better
place
philanthropy programs also try to enable
that encouraging people with matching
programs to donate equipment to schools
and other nonprofit organizations as
well as to make financial contributions
with matching programs around the not
total outside but in or outside were the
three main areas of active engagement
driven by HP's business and HP strategy
so one of the very significant things
about our thinking about global
citizenship was that a it should be
directly linked to the business strategy
the company and we treated it that way
when we went through the annual
strategic planning process this was part
of it and we looked at what was
happening on the business side and the
things that we were trying to accomplish
and the vulnerabilities that we were
seeing from a competitive perspective
and tried to drive the priorities from a
citizenship perspective to be aligned
with that and so the three areas that
made sense were privacy because of our
business privacy was a big issue
environment environment had been a life
long focus of the company
partly because Hewlett and Packard were
environmentalists and this was a concern
from before the time it was popped
to worry about the environment and
finally inclusion in education inclusion
was the term that we used to describe
using technology to accelerate economic
development and that was probably the
area where we were doing the most
groundbreaking work we had two very
significant projects one in Africa one
in South Africa in a rural village near
Zimbabwe and one in under Pradesh in
India where we put significant full-time
teams 20 plus people on the ground to
work in collaboration with the local
community with government and with
nonprofit organizations to try to really
figure out how technology could
accelerate development in those
communities really interesting things
came out the strategy was both a
community contribution strategy and a
business development strategy we looked
at these rural developing parts of the
world and said there are a lot of people
who if we could give them technology
that was really suited to their
environment in their specific needs at a
price that made sense given the value
then it's a big business opportunity and
obviously it was also an opportunity to
have any impact in terms of global
development so I want to talk a little
bit about stakeholder engagement in
these areas and I want to come back to a
couple comments that were made during a
little tail end after I came in our
strategy was to actively engage even
with some fringe stakeholders and so in
the area of environment as an example
the Silicon Valley toxics coalition had
always been a little on the sort of
guerilla warfare side of the equation
and we had been in their sights we were
a big organization we make a lot of
stuff and they had some significant
concerns about that and we decided we
didn't know where this is going to go
but we're gonna sit down and talk to
these guys because for a variety of
reasons we believed
that part of what pisses these
organizations off is being just
dismissed being treated as though
they're not even worth a conversation
and so we sat at the table and had
dialogue and tried to understand their
perspective and try to help them
understand ours and I would say in every
case and we engaged with lots of
organizations in every case it moved the
ball forward in a positive way we didn't
always agree but never did it backfire
you said well maybe they would be more
angry because they made a suggestion and
you didn't follow up on it
if we could rationally explain why we
were doing what we were doing and not
doing what they thought the best idea
was it was always the case that they
felt less hostile towards us for having
engaged they didn't necessarily love us
and they didn't necessarily get out
there and say Yahoo these guys are the
greatest thing that ever happened to the
environment but it they valued the being
listened to and when we genuinely
listened to them it always worked I
think if you engage with people in a way
that's condescending and dismissive it
can really backfire and so the intent
and the manner have to be authentic but
our experience was always very positive
there our engagement in the inclusion
communities was very broad and very
interesting partly because we were
learning a ton we were engaging with all
kinds of organizations big development
organizations like the UN and little
nonprofit organizations working in
Africa doing all kinds of things or
working in India doing all kinds of
things they had different agendas for us
some of them you know just thought oh
these guys have a lot of money they can
give it to us but that was a joy
an opportunity to learn about what was
happening in those environments from a
radically different perspective the
outside of this triangle is basically
the levers that we used primary levers
that we used in going after these
various issue areas so we had a big
policy team we did government work
around the world and this is another
area where engaging with fringe
organizations was very helpful I mean we
would sometimes collaborate on trying to
come up with policy in the environmental
area as an example that would address
environmental concerns and we were
pretty aggressive in the environmental
area so we actually wanted to raise a
bar on regulation we felt that
competitively we would be better served
we would prefer to have a more level
playing field and so in our regulatory
work we did a lot of engagement with
activist groups and other sometimes
fringe kinds of groups we used
philanthropy very strategically and that
was I think a very significant part of
our strategy so the idea of just giving
out money randomly to people because
giving away money is something company
should do didn't make sense to us or our
philanthropy budget which at the time
was about fifty to sixty million dollars
a year it wasn't huge it went into two
buckets one was employee engagement
I mentioned encouraging employees to
give equipment to give money and doing
matching and the other was strategic
initiatives in the areas that I've
talked about other than that we
minimized giving away money for the
kinds of things that companies often
give money for a benefit here you know a
little random scattershot investments
and communication was also another key
area a lot of disclosure extensive
reporting
really trying to raise the bar in
transparency so I want to come back to
the chart that I showed about changing
weight of what stakeholders got paid
attention to and I want to reflect just
a little bit on some of why I think the
weight shifted somewhat some is obvious
maybe all of its obvious to you some
perhaps not so obvious obviously the
death of the founders had a big
influence and my husband and I now when
we drive past HP say that's why you
should never name a company after
yourself just don't know and you might
be mortified clearly that was a major
factor Wall Street has a lot more
influence today than they had 60 years
ago this obsession with quarterly
earnings that just drives a lot of
management teams just wasn't so much the
reality and I think that serves not only
to raise the focus on investors but also
to drive this short-term view that's
very negative from a number of
perspectives it has been globalized for
a long long time but I think with
increasing globalization comes a sense
of detachment from the community of
corporate leaders so you know when HP
started it was a little Palo Alto
company and Bill and Dave were
significant members of the community
here they served on the school board
they had kids in school their multiple
identities all came together in this
environment they were businessmen yes
trying to run a successful business but
they were also community leaders
and sportsmen and environmentalists and
activists and when I reflect on the
history of HP and I reflect on the state
of business today one of the things that
I lament is what I would generally call
dis integration I think that somewhat
uniquely for their time youlet and
Packard embraced their multiple
identities in the way they led the
company and because of that it was very
natural for them to think HP should
worry about the environment they cared
about the environment they wanted to be
able to be in clean air in beautiful
pristine places fishing and doing the
kinds of things they love to do they
knew about government they participated
in government at the local level
ultimately Dave took a leave of absence
and was assistant deputy at the national
level they viewed themselves as more of
a part of multiple arenas of society and
that's true to some extent today but I
think more rare I think it's more
typical to embrace Friedman's view that
companies make as much money as they can
possibly make and don't worry about the
rest of that stuff somebody else will
worry about it which is a very
disintegrated approach the last point up
here is rising consumerism consumers
play in this shift as well it was not so
much the case in the 30s when HP started
that consumers were pretty
single-mindedly fixated on getting more
for less they were focused on other
things and they were buying from smaller
organizations for the most part and so
they could pay attention to the impact
that a company had both through their
product but through the way they showed
up in the community and the kinds of
things they did there were more natural
checks and natural balances in that
system
so Chris asked me to reflect before I
open this up on to a little Q&A on what
would it take to solve the big social
and environmental problems of our time
and this is certainly something that I
spend a lot of energy on now I I doubt
that I will ever go back into the
corporate world in any full-time way and
there did that great experience and now
I'm really focused on trying to have an
impact in a couple of ways the construct
of business is a great concern to me and
so I'm active in B lab which you'll
learn more about trying to create a new
business sector I'm very involved in
social entrepreneurs in trying to bring
some of the tools of business and
entrepreneurship to people who are
single-mindedly focused on trying to
change the world that's where I spend my
time and having the business background
that I have and believing that business
is absolutely essential we will never
ever ever ever address the big social
environmental issues of our time without
having business squarely engaged in
helping to address those issues i
synthesize my thoughts about what it
will take into this little 2x2 because
after going to Harvard my brain is
pretty much a two by two I don't know if
you're all undergoing but that same
re-engineering of your brain but I think
there are two dimensions that need to
shift one is the timeframe of
consideration I think this is true at
the individual level I also think it's
true at the organizational level
particularly for businesses so we need
to start thinking longer-term but I also
think we need to shift from thinking
about impact only at the individual
level or the individual company level
more in the direction
of thinking about impact on communities
society the planet and the inhabitants
that's much more complicated that is
moving much more in the direction of a
very interconnected
view the integrated approach to thinking
about decisions that I mentioned as
being part of the hallmark of the way
you land and Packard approached their
role as business leaders and I think the
good news about taking that perspective
is while it's hard it's so much easier
to focus on one thing every day life
would be really easy if you could just
focus on one thing but at the end of the
day I don't think it's very gratifying
to segment your life into these
disconnected buckets when you're in the
community you're one way and when you're
in business you're another way and it's
just kind of not all that gratifying so
making this transition while difficult I
think leads to more overall satisfaction
when one can achieve it which is always
another good thing to aspire to so with
that let me open the floor and take
questions about things that might have
been intriguing to you so I just have to
talk and say thank you to our YouTube
viewers and we'll see you possibly in
another two weeks thank you